[Music]  the case before you today is a simple  one the defendant my Glasser Stan we  murdered his father you can't let him  cry son if it always sounds bad indicate  they weren't taking bets on this world  Mike must his handprint on the knife  confessed he said I did but I knew  enough about the last stuff to know that  Mike had a defense dad was always  threatening me so he was my husband  could be exceptionally cruel  it feels so one-sided is it possible  he's not saying what really happened  well I don't know you think you know I  did Mike see in here your husband hit me  yes but if Mike didn't stab his father I  have to defend it without no non-sex how  do we know any of it happen  we stick to the strategy it's like  you're protecting her I ask for your  help and keeping spoil prison shouldn't  even be on trial this testimony has  clearly been arranged in Reverse a  witness's star  that remains you to decide is why hello  he asking me on a date